>> ♪ ♪
>> EVEN THIS GUY IS GIVING
ADVICE ON HOW TO AVOID POLITICS
AT THANKSGIVING.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING HOME AND
GETTING NERVOUS ABOUT ARGUING
WITH YOUR MOM OR DAD OR AUNT OR
UNCLE, THE POINT TO BE MADE IS
THAT WHAT WE ARE FIGHTING FOR,
THE VALUES WE ARE FIGHTING FOR
ARE REALLY NOT NEW VALUES.
I THINK PEOPLE IF YOU TALK TO
THEM UNDERSTAND THAT.
THEY WILL HAVE A HARD TIME
EXPLAINING WHY IT'S OKAY FOR
THREE PEOPLE TO OWN MORE WEALTH
THAN THE BOTTOM HALF OF AMERICA
AND WHY SOME CORPORATIONS PAY
NOTHING IN TEXAS.
>> HE SAID LET'S UNIFY AND THEN
SLAMS THE RICH.
WE ARE DIFFERENT AT "THE FIVE."
WE LIKE A QUICK KNOCKOUT.
70% OF RICH AMERICANS GREW UP IN
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THEY MOVED UP.
HOW ELSE COULD BERNIE SANDERS
AFFORD SO MANY HOMES?
HE MOVED UP THE LADDER HE CLAIMS
DIDN'T EXIST.
YOU WANT TO TALK IMPEACHMENT.
GOOD LUCK IMPEACHING TRUMP FOR
UNCOVERING CORRUPTION.
QUID PRO QUO?
THAT'S LIFE.
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO GET
SOMETHING FOR NOTHING BUT THAT
INVOLVES KILLING.
BARTERING BEATS BOMBING.
THE ORANGE MAN FINISHED THEM OFF
AND LET THE DOG HAVE THE LAST
LAUGH.
HOW ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE?
WHAT IS YOUR POSITION ON CHINA?
THE WORLD'S WORST FOSSILE FUEL
POLLUTER.
CHINA GETS A PASS.
I WILL LISTEN TO BILL GATES WHO
SAYS NUCLEAR IS A VITAL ENERGY
SOURCE TO CUT OUT CARBON
EMISSIONS.
YES, DONALD TRUMP IS BAD.
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN
DECADES.
BLACKS, WOMEN AND HISPANICS
DOING BETTER THAN UNDER OBAMA
AND BODIES ARE NOT COMING HOME
IN COFFINS.
HERE'S WHAT TRUMP TWEETED TODAY.
THE MEDIA DESCRIBED IT AS
DOCTORED.
THANK YOU, GENIUSES.
WE ARE SO GOING TO MISS HIM WHEN
HE IS GONE IN 2024.
TRUMP CHANGED POLITICS.
YOU HAVE LEFTISTS CALLING OUT
THE PHONEY DOSSIER AND THIS NUT
MOCKING BLACK CONSERVATIVES.
IT'S CRUMBLING.
SIT BACK AND ENJOY THE MALE.
-- MEAL.
MAYBE THIS YEAR I GET TO SIT
WITH THE GROWNUPS.
>> WE NEED BETTER TOPICS.
JUAN, MASH OR MASHED POTATOES.
I SAY MASH?
>> WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
>> SOME SAY MASH AND OTHERS SAY
MASHED.
THAT'S TWO EXTRA LETTERS YOU
DON'T NEED.
>> IT'S THE SAME ON THE PLATE.
>> PASS THE MASH OR MASHED?
>> MASHED.
>> I LEARNED MASH AT A YOUNG
AGE.
>> IS THAT A WEST COAST THING?
>> I DON'T KNOW
>> NO, MASHED.
I AM FROM THE SAME WEST COAST.
>> THE DANCE IS THE MASH POTATO.
>> OH, THE DANCE!
>> EXACTLY.
>> THAT MAY BE WHERE YOU GOT IT
TWINKLE TOES.
>> THIS IS WHY WE DEBATE
POLITICS, JUAN, BECAUSE THAT
DIDN'T WORK.
>> IT TOOK ME A SECOND.
THE MONSTER MASH!
I HAVE NO EXCUSE.
EVEN TEXANS SAY MASHED.
>> I HAVE NOT GOTTEN TO YOU YET.
>> YOU WERE AT THE KIDS TABLE,
DUDE.
>> HERE'S THE DEBATE.
>> DON'T DO IT.
>> LAWRENCE HAS STRONG FEELINGS
ON WHO IS A REAL COUNTRY SING
AND WHO ISN'T.
>> YES, IN THE GREENROOM WE HAD
A BIG DEBATE.
>> I DIDN'T LIKE COUNTRY.
TRAVIS TRITT BROUGHT ME TO
COUNTRY.
>> YOU SAID YOU LIKED THE OLD
>> WHAT?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> HE LIKES CHRIS STAPLETON.
I AGREE.
>> SOULFUL.
>> I SAID WHAT ABOUT TOBY
KEATING?
I PLAYED COURTESY OF THE RED,
WHITE AND BLUE.
HE SAID THAT'S HORRIBLE.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THE RED, WHITE
AND BLUE WAS HORRIBLE.
THE SINGING WAS HORRIBLE.
IT WAS DEPRESSING.
>> OH!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> IF YOU ARE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION, I WILL BE LIKE, I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
COUNTRY MUSIC.
>> EVERYBODY WOULD GANG UP ON
YOU AT A REALLY THANKSGIVING.
>> DANA, THE SONG OF THE YEAR?
>> THE SONG OF THE YEAR WE ALL
KNOW.
SHUT UP ABOUT POLITICS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S THE SONG OF THE YEAR.
>> THAT'S SO TRUE.
EMILY, DO YOU HAVE SPIRITED
DEBATES OVER THANKSGIVING?
>> WE TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING.
I GROW UP HAVING DINNER WITH MY
WHOLE FAMILY EVERY NIGHT.
IT WAS ABOUT CONVERSATION AND
CONNECTION.
I FEEL LIKE THAT'S WHY I LOVE
STORY TELLING.
I LOVE LISTENING TO PEOPLE'S
OPINIONS.
I LEARN SO MUCH.
IT WAS A HISTORY LESSON EVERY
NIGHT.
I LEARNED ABOUT MY FAMILY'S
TRADITIONS AND CULTURE.
WAS AWESOME.
I KNOW PART IS WHAT IS OUR
ADVICE FOR WHEN YOU DEFENSIVE
LINE INTO POLITICS.
-- DWELVE INTO POLITICS.
REMEMBER IT'S YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
>> BUT YOU DON'T LOVE THEM.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> KEEP THAT IN MIND.
>> I LOVE MY LOVED ONES, BUT I
NEVER START TALKING ABOUT.
I DO THIS FOR A LIVING.
I WANT TO CHILL.
>> ON YOUR SHOW EARLIER, YOUR
THANKSGIVING IS NOT A TALK SHOW?
>> RIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE US.
>> EXACTLY.
EVERYBODY SHOULD JUST CHILL OUT
AND TALK ABOUT OTHER THINGS.
>> I WOULD RATHER HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT RELIGION.
>> YES!
>> WHY NOT?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I WANT TO DEBATE LAWRENCE
ABOUT COUNTRY MUSIC.
>> BERNIE SANDERS'S POINT IS
INTERESTING.
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT VALUES.
COMMON VALUES.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT, WAIT A MINUTE.
HE SAYS THAT THREE PEOPLE HAVE
MORE WEALTH THAN HALF THE
COUNTRY.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S NOT BRING IT UP BECAUSE I
LOVE YOU, AUNTIE.
OR WHEN BERNIE SANDERS SAYS, HOW
CAN IT BE THAT THESE BIG
CORPORATIONS PAY NO TAXES AND
YOU PAY TAXES?
UNCLE, LEAVE IT ALONE.
LET'S GO AFTER THE RICH PEOPLE.
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN POOR YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE.
YOU GET A LITTLE MONEY AND THEY
WANT TO TAKE YOU FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE GOT.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
IF I SAY PASS ME THE TURKEY.
LAWRENCE.
IS THAT RIGHT?
OBAMA ONLY SENT SHEETS AND
PILLOWS TO THE UKRAINIANS.
IT'S ALWAYS AT THE LIBERALS AT
THE DINNER TABLE THAT WHINE AND
CRY.
>> GREG TOLD ME DRINK TO EXCESS.
>> YES!
>> JUAN, AT THIS TABLE WHEN WE
DISAGREE DO YOU THINK WE HAVE
THE SAME VALUES AND THE QUESTION
OF WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR IT,
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY WE AGREE ON
VALUES?
>> YES, FOR ME IT'S AN
INTERESTING QUESTION.
I THINK TRUMP IS POLARIZING.
BUT THE REALITY IS WHAT BERNIE
SANDERS SAID.
MOST OF US HAVE VALUES ABOUT
LOVING THIS COUNTRY AND WANTING
OUR CHILDREN TO DO BETTER AND
BELIEF IN THE NOTION OF
NEIGHBORS HELPING NEIGHBORS.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS A BIG
ARGUMENT.
>> NO, I HATE MY NEIGHBORS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I WOULD PREFER LIVING ON AN
ISLAND.
>> AND YOU LIKE MOCKING DANA
PERINO?
>> YES.
I NEVER TALK ABOUT POLITICS, BUT
WE ARE HAVING GUESTS WHO HAVE
ISSUES WITH SOME OF THE SORT OF
THINGS I DO FOR A LIVING.
I WILL LISTEN TO MUSIC AND GET
DRUNK.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> JUST REMEMBER THAT PEOPLE
LOVE TO TALK ABOUT THEMSELVES.
JUST ASK THEM ABOUT THEMSELVES.
GET TO KNOW THEM.
>> [LAUGHING].